alright guys Luke Tom Nate shanley and
my brother Dan here with the outdoor
boy's YouTube channel and today we're
going Towe Dunton alright guys so my
brother and his daughter are here
visiting from Alaska and it's a
beautiful summer night it's warm the Sun
is setting we gotta go toad huntin so
are you guys excited that was kind of
lurking there wasn't it Thank You Tommy
for saving my life there's one up here
check out that one up there he's a
pretty good-sized one too now there's no
brown recluses here take this one out
here in this town you'll see there's
just a little toad shape thing sitting
on the size of millipedes are friendly
centipedes are the nasty one oh no that
gives white lights and
oh that's how you show me Sylvie you're
doing
show me you toad yeah yeah it works with
frogs but yeah first frog yeah does that
tickle Nathan gentle okay show the
camera I remember catch these in Hawaii
[Music]
he's too quick go for it
earlier those guys
he's got a really green pellet usually
some green mantis well watch out he's
gonna fly yeah he's got wings she's got
wings I don't think they're gonna hurt
go straight for Dan oh yeah
sure let him go yeah okay guys come over
here we're gonna let him go over here oh
you got one just lay on the ground and
eat nice better one we've had a
successful night toad hunting and now
we're gonna celebrate with a little
campfire in the driveway well guys I
hope you enjoyed this video and if you
want to see more great videos from the
outdoor boy's YouTube channel don't
forget to click subscribe thanks for
watching guys
[Music]